Gulf of Tonkin,
Eh,
or,
or Jesse Smollett.
I mean,
I couldn't help,
but I knew he'd probably sue me the day after it happened.
I said,
the guy's got a noose around his neck at 2:00 AM in,
in Chicago,
and to cause a noose in Chicago who's walking around with a news,
who even knows how to write,
who,
who knows how to make a noose,
like who?
Then the cops show up 40 something minutes later and he's at the door with a
noose around a snack,
homing subway sandwich.
Fake.
I said,
sue me,
destroy me by it's fate.
I can't help but see,
the problem is that's that.
That's where the psychosis comes in.
Because if you,
if you're a little kid is,
I've been read more about psychology,
trying to understand this stuff.
If you're a little kid and somebody with red hair beat you and tortured,
you have a say man with red hair.
I'm just a hypothetical.
What?
You're going to not like guys with red hair.
So,
so,
so it's kind of like,
or if you've been lied to as a kid,
let it,
that's what creates mental illness layer,
right?
So we've been lucky with the media and the corporate system and seeing all these
fake hoaxes and you know,
the fake stuff about Cavenaugh and the face of about the coverage of kids and,
and the face of about smaller,
she,
that's now the public actually,
here's what's happening.
I'm getting huge backlash and small it,
it's not,
wait a minute,
who's given you backlash?
And the public are like,
Hey,
smallest fake the coverage.
Kids are fake.
Polozzi Ford.
And most of these women said it was all fake.
So why are you saying Sandy Hook's real?
Everything's fake.
And it's like,
no dude,
everything's not faith.
That's what I'm saying is the differential is gone.
And so yeah,
there's a bunch of fake stuff and we have a right to question it.
But now,
now,
then now the general public,
my fans believe everything's fake.
But let me stop you there.
I'm ranting.
I just,
it's okay.
I want you to ramp this,
but this is,
this is the nature of the beast.
This is what you're selling to a lot of these people.
This is why they're tuning into you.
They want to hear you uncover conspiracies,
and some of them aren't as bright as others,
and some of them can't see logic.
They don't see it.
They don't understand.
I'm legitimately questioning.
I don't just think everything's fake.